[Musique]
nouvelle étape de notre moi président
tour est toujours la même question si
vous oui vous vous étiez un candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
qu'auriez vous dit pour convaincre les
électeurs à fort de france
la question fait sourire mais surtout
réfléchir et autant dire que le lieu s'y
prête au compromis vous en quoi les gens
pensent qu'on a
c'est rock les jeunes emploi et désabusé
on ceux qui en ont besoin et qu'on se
croyait table
en coulisses et qu'en est-il de celle
qui côtoie au quotidien tous ses livres
il faut dire la vérité c'est important
la vérité parce qu'on se rend compte
finalement que
chaque fois qu'un candidat et ses
d'émerger des choses ressortent des
choses qui étaient cachées pour les
étudiants qui ce jour-là travail sur le
sujet de la corée du nord
il est clair qu'être candidat ça ne
s'improvise pas choisi
aux électeurs
tu m'aurais dit donc améliorer le ruiner
il faut avoir la possible
armes pour mai
sur tenir cette promesse est offert le
meilleur de soi même
[Musique]
on reste sur le territoire kacem
bienvenue à schoelcher sable chaud
température de la mer 25 degrés et voilà
notre micro qui se baladent par là même
durant une petite séance de bronzage
on prend le temps de nous répondre aux
questions qu'est ce que je ferais en
fait
bah je pense que j'essaierai de
vachement aider les pauvres en fait
parce que je trouve que les présidents
est ce que les candidats aient pris il
propose ça avance ça avantage beaucoup
une certaine classe de la société parce
que même si on dit qu'à plus de classe
mais je trouve qu'il ya vraiment des
classes il se trouve que ça arrange ça
avantage beaucoup par exemple la
bourgeoisie et non nous en fait les gens
du peuple en fait
bah écoutez moi je veux penser à mon
peuple au mien puisque nous sommes des
insulaires on est des dons bien donc je
pense qu'il serait intéressant que les
hommes soient réellement pris en
considération par rapport à la cherté de
la vie par rapport aux par rapport aux
taxes et aux difficultés que l'on
rencontre d'une certaine manière et à
l'éducation parce que pour vous va pas
se mentir dû qu'à partir du collège
d'éducation ça part en sucette
dans le genre où certains gènes et
j'aimerais commencer à s'épanouir plutôt
dans leurs activités qu'on parle
français ou presque peut importe on a
aussi la réponse à la question il ya un
peu trop de sentiments den den
aujourd'hui et donc je ferai seulement
un jeu les je dirais ok vous savez quoi
tout qu'est ce que vous voulez tout ce
que vous lui faire c'est possible mais
tranquillement calmement et avec eux
vous savez avec de la constance
voilà c'est dit prochaine étape de notre
tour des communes à la recherche de
réponse à notre question ans d'arlet et
rivière pilote et autant dire que ça
promet